this one
[Music]
what is that
[Music]
i'm pregnant
[Music]
hey guys so i wanted to do a video my
mom my brothers are here too
and you guys have been dying to see me
and my mom play animal crossing together
before we begin i wanted to show
everyone what i did in my house so check
this out
i created a new room
isn't this cute
ignore the cockroach because i haven't
been here for a long time
do you like the room oh
cute
yeah
nursery home
because
i'm pregnant
are you serious
yeah
oh my gosh
[Music]
[Music]
is that a russian or something
can you read it i thought it was
streaming oh can you read my shirt um
bye-bye
huh can you read my shirt
can you straight
okay
my shirt was wrong
[Applause]
you can stop asking me okay what does it
say with us to say right now
it says i am pregnant oh that's a funny
t-shirt
you can stop asking now what does your
shirt say
sure can you read it
no not really i can't what is the second
i
no i can't read that let me see can you
read it
now
oh wait i am
[Music]
yeah
ready yeah
[Applause]
we're having a baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
okay good all right good ready yeah
let's go
[Music]
after
i've never seen that one
i have this one deal with it what
huh what i've never seen that one
lady
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is she holding twins
i know
something i have this one
[Applause]
is it twins
check this out
[Music]
congratulations
it's like it's like mad again right you
know what's happening right now yes
try reading the shirt i can't see though
[Music]
[Music]
well can you read it oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is what you were pregnant again
this time we made it to the doctor's
visit
yeah i'm so happy oh my god yeah because
i wanted to tell you that i ain't
pregnant you're pregnant oh
let me see that
thank you girlfriend
oh my god that took a difference
i know right
but now that we're all together i wanted
to tell you guys i'm pregnant no
no
[Laughter]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Laughter]
so i wanted to show you
ready
i'm pregnant
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
remember two days ago i was talking to
you about this i told you eat some
oysters yeah
that's before i knew too it was really
yeah
[Laughter]
that's delicious
delicious come here gonna be a big
brother and sister
he's gonna be a big sister
oh my gosh i'm so happy
[Applause]
but you know what mom i've actually had
this room for a long time
because i was actually pregnant before
and i lost it and that's why i haven't
been playing animal crossing because i'm
like makes me sad
[Music]
i know
i wish i could hug you
cause i was like confusing trying to
figure out what that is and how this
like confused and now now he's saying
you know what i'm getting goosebumps
[Music]
you know what when you do the shirt
that's why i was so confused because i
read i am perfect i didn't see i am
pregnant
all right i just heard no idea that's
also very true yeah i want to try and
figure it now what's that then i saw i
think i saw it like i'm perfect and then
you undo the shirt real quick you know i
got it right away
[Laughter]
baby
[Music]
i can't wait to play with you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you